an explosion at a chemical plant in
Texas rocked an entire neighborhood
overnight prompting evacuations there
that stretched over half a mile radius
doorbell video shows a moment of the
explosion in Port Neches witnesses say
it was felt miles away police say there
is extensive damage throughout the city
the company that owns this plant says
three people have minor injuries now the
fire is still burning in Port Neches
which is about 85 miles east of Houston
Michele joy of our Houston affiliate
that's KHOU reports from near the scene
good morning the plant where this
explosion happened produces chemical and
petroleum based products however the
exact cause remains under investigation
video posted to social media shows just
how intense these flames were people
living in Port Neches say they heard a
blast shortly after 1:00 a.m. the
explosion blew out windows of homes that
were several miles away emergency
response crews went door-to-door
evacuating people from their homes as
the fire burned out of control there are
also reports of damage to area
businesses and a school this part of
Texas is a major hub for oil and gas
industries the company that owns the
plant says on its website that it
employs more than 200 people for CBS
this morning I'm Michele Choi